(upbeat music playing)
- All right.
Oh my gosh. I love seeing the rink.
That was so cool with the
Kelly Clarkson Show on it.
We're very fancy here at 30 Rock.
Band, you are sounding incredible today.
Give it up for the band.
(crowd cheering)
Well, everybody, we've got time
for one more story I
discovered on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music playing)
I think we all sat in disbelief
seeing the devastation
in Maui after the fires this summer.
It's one of those moments when you think
what can I do to help?
And that's exactly what went
through five-year-old Edison's mind.
His solution? A lemonade
stand, which is incredible.
So with the help of his parents
he whipped up yellow and pink lemonade,
set up a table and posted a vibrant sign.
And in one day he
raised, get this, $20,000
(crowd applauding)
for the Maui Relief Fund.
Lemonade is powerful.
Beyonce knew. She knew!
We have Edison and his mom Amy
on the line right now watching from home
on KOMO 4 in Seattle.
What's up Edison? What's up mama?
- Hello.
- Hi.
- Oh my gosh. So Amy,
how did this all start?
- Yeah, so we took Edison
to Lahaina back in January.
So when we were watching
the news about the fires
he knew what, where we were talking about.
He remembered our trip there
and I think he felt really sad hearing
about the kids and parents
who had lost so much.
And so we were on a walk
one night as a family
and he said, maybe we
can have a lemonade stand
and I can give all my money
to the people in Lahaina.
And my husband and I looked at each other
and we thought, how can we,
we have to make that happen.
That's such a cool idea.
And so he sat all day out on a Saturday
and raised a lot of money.
Everything was listed at one dollar
but everyone gave a lot more than that.
- I noticed from the twenty grand. Yeah.
I was like, that is good lemonade.
You should open an
establishment at that point.
Well, Edison, how does it make you feel
to help these people that needed the help?
- Happy and proud
because I helped everyone.
- Absolutely the best feeling too.
Being happy, helping
others makes you happy.
I think we forget that sometimes.
Thank you for reminding us Edison.
You guys, y'all are amazing
and thank you so much.
Amy and Edison, I'm liking
your post right now, Okay?
- [Edison] Yeah.
- He's so cute.
Well, that's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate your kind heart
so they're giving the Maui
Strong Fund a thousand dollars
to help even more people in Lahaina.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you guys so much.
Congrats on your lemonade stand
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Leslie Odom Jr., Mike Birbiglia,
Jackie, Matt and Bryan
from The Awesome Company.
Y'all have a great day.
(crowd cheering)